Welcome to Christmas Prague.
This is the famous Christmas market on Old Town Square,...
...but it's very touristy.
So let me first show you some other Christmas markets around Prague.
Christmas markets on Jirak and Mirak are, in general, much cheaper and visited by locals.
You will hardly find a tourist here.
Benefit of the Christmas markets here is that you can find something like this,...
...which is homemade Christmas sweets.
Another Christmas market really close by,...
...just one subway stop, are these on Jiriho Z Podebrad, or we refer to it "Jirak."
They're pretty empty now,...
...but on weekends, there's gonna be a farmer market attached to it.
So if you're here on a weekend, I would come here.
One of the reasons to visit Jirak is also this church by Plecnik.
And we're back on the Old Town Square.
So let me show you what you can buy around here.
Some food like hotdog or gulas soup, so-so.
Hot wine. Yeah!
Roasted chestnuts, so-so.